[Music]
a way out is not the hard-hitting
emotional tale of two convicts escaping
prison it appears to be at times it
successfully strikes those nose but
extreme tonal shifts gimmicky cuties and
a terrible finale kill almost any
emotional tension contained in the game
in the end entertaining environment and
some inventive set pieces proved a bit
saving grace like director Joseph Farah
says last game brothers a tale of two
tons a way out contains two protagonists
who experience the story together
but unlike brothers you'll need a friend
to play with this time around a wire is
only playable in co-op either locally or
online whichever you choose you'll
always be playing in a split screen that
dynamically shifts between the
respective views of a reckless
aggressive gangster cliche named Leo and
a more cool-headed family man in Vincent
this framing device is mostly used in
interesting ways such as giving more
screen space to whoever's performing a
more important action or splitting the
TV and three two also dedicate real
estate to an attacking NPC however it
can irritate like when my partner
triggered a cutscene while I was halfway
through exploring or when you both
engage in separate conversations meaning
two sets of dialogue overlap are you
saying it's all in my head but these
issues are more of a footnote than a
major strike against away outs co-op
only nature without a partner in crime
some of the game's standout moments
wouldn't feel as impactful in one early
scene Leo and Vincent are attempting to
hack away at their jail cells using a
screwdriver while your partner stabs the
wall behind his toilet you must keep
watch from your adjacent cell for
patrolling guards occupying them when
they get too close and warning the other
player to look natural when your
distraction fails I can't sleep do you
have a book I could read what do I look
like a librarian this is when a way out
is at its best
communicating with and relying on your
partner both in game and in real life
makes these moments of tension
consistently thrilling there are a
handful of these set pieces throughout
the seven to eight hour campaign that
feel unique and they justify the
decision of forcing you to play with
another person
but while those moments do carry some
tension it's because you're sat next to
someone you care about and never because
you're playing as someone you care for
the protagonists and their motivations
are the most generic b-movie fodder
gangsters with escape and revenge on
their minds but with the hackneyed added
layer of troubled families to make
matters worse the dialogue is stilted
and unnatural conversations often end
abruptly regardless of whether your
partner triggers a cutscene too early
and entire scenes go by without adding
anything in terms of plot or
characterization some lines in
particular are cringe-worthy during one
sequence in which a couple are
interrupted while having sex
a female extra instructs her male
partner to shut the door because the
tone veers wildly from a Shawshank
inspired escape tale - a silly semi
parody of 70s crime dramas complete with
overextended sideburns an assassination
across the border and a villains remote
Mexican lair in one scene away is
nailing the feel of punishing prison
life but in another it's letting you act
like children on a playground swing
sometimes those conflicting tones even
happen in parallel one poignant
late-game moment when my character
learned some surprising and emotional
news on one side of the screen was
ruined by my partner interacting with a
bicycle Bell on the other side that
caused his character to exclaim I need
to fly somewhere tomorrow if it's not
the dialogue dampening moments of
tension is the game's numerous QTEs
while away out does use time button
tapping well in some instances such as
when our characters must time there
pushes up a vent shaft while standing
back-to-back it also wastes scenes with
gimmicky implementations like mashing
square or X as quickly as possible
pure luck I slip away at its third and
fourth acts are by far its weakest save
for one inventive story beat all
creativity is lost and the game turns
into a mediocre action romp with anemic
shooting and little else to do or care
about
luckily the rest of the game which is
much longer than the mercifully
contracted finale contains more
interesting and varied environment these
diverse areas are small but dense and
the add color to what could otherwise be
a monochrome world of good and bad the
trailer park was a personal favorite
offering a chance to pause and play some
baseball nice or chat some secondary
characters but this captivating space
comes during what should be a time
sensitive moment in the plot when
playing baseball or mocking around on
swings would be the last things on
anyone's mind and this says everything
about a wet story in tone by the time
the credits rolled my partner and I
didn't really feel like we'd been on
much of a journey with Leo and Vincent
we'd been on a geographical tour sure
but we didn't feel like the pair had
learned anything or grown in any
meaningful way but I did enjoy the
journey I've been on with my friends sat
next to me we'd had to look out for each
other while escaping prison work
together to solve puzzles and save each
other's life for multiple occasions our
characters might not have grown closer
together but aware it's forced co-op is
worth it the few standout moments it
provides by the way what are you in for
something I didn't do so you're innocent
huh well aren't we all
I'm innocent too you know yeah I'm sure
you are